[Music]
hi everyone welcome back to Friday face
up at me Bianca the website at a Tara
clammy UK and today I'm joined by star
makeup in front sir
Gary aka the plastic boy so today we're
going head-to-head to recreate a makeup
look that we've never seen before
in just five minutes Oh professional I
think I should be worried five minutes
like that is five minutes of makeup look
I think I've a consumer I think
[Music]
oh hey pop-ups yeah pop heart definitely
we're gonna take five hours not five
minutes ten minutes but I think I've got
it's just the dots but five minutes says
why how are you gonna tackle this okay
so I'm gonna go over the dots first cuz
that's the most hardest part if we're
gonna do a few dots here and there
place it first and I think I'm gonna do
the lip because those are the main
components then I'll start with the
shading on the brows and then the
eyeliner but the dots the main bit first
taking notes copy math you ready to get
to it ready so Gary what products have
you got around that so I've got the Max
Factor red lipstick this is in Ruby
Tuesday this would be amazing to like
the regular it's like so creamy also got
this L'Oreal Paris like white Kajal
paradise kind of eyeliner pen what
products have you got over there hon
I've got some lash perfect strip lashes
which I have no idea how to apply some
glue are you gonna applying lashes
yes okay great this mua makeup academy
brow define eyebrow pencil and then i've
obviously also got the l'oreal paris pan
which it's gonna become very handled
creating the hundreds of dots on my face
yes but some pieces crack them with you
starting with the dots fire yes I'm
wasting time it's really oh no oh that's
me actually I've already how many how
many don't speed up about twenty do my
pen is falling apart
we can do this we can do this look I'm
ill I'm so
I never wear lipstick so I don't even
after doing the white in the eye as well
what is lipsticks really creamy okay
much better nice what you are now I am
basically turning myself into clown boy
shot waterproof coal liner and space
night drawing lines leave my face
panicking
throwing things everywhere are you using
the brow define for the brows I'm
guessing yeah fine do you do I know you
cheeks I'm really over boarded the gluon
oh it's all in my fingers so nauseous
what you doing now your lashes this
lashes book but it's aho type in my I
know my sad small dollar man please stay
close to us doing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you inning Oh easy like I don't
know a long gun like the Tacoma show
y'all find the hardest everything I mean
look at me
the eyelashes I'm never gonna try and
wear these this is not a little bit of
where the brows a piece of Friday night
look babe thank you so much for watching
Friday face off make sure you like and
subscribe to glamour UK's YouTube
channel for more videos just like this
bye
[Music]
you